Okay. So would you trust a religion that
has corrupted scripture?
>> I said it's not having any corrupted or
anything. It's good and it's pure. Islam
is most beautiful and trustworthy. So
what is the problem with Islam that
talking about
>> beautiful beautiful and trustworthy
logic? Come on man.
>> It is it is because we believe how you
going to rebut that in one god. At least
we believe in one god. That's right. We
believe in 20. That's the most beautiful
of it. Would you trust a religion that
has corrupted scripture my sister in
humanity?
>> I said there is no any scripture or
anything. I said it's beautiful.
>> I'm not saying I'm just asking you a
simple question. Would you or would you
not trust a religion that has corrupted
scripture?
>> I don't know about other religion. I
believe in Islam. Islam is not is
scripture or anything. It is clear.
That's all I said.
>> So the if your religion is Christian,
>> let me ask you this.
>> So you believe in Christian? I
>> let me let me ask you this. Let me ask
you this. If Islam if Islam had
corrupted scripture within its religion,
would you trust Islam?
>> This Islam? Yes. Still.
>> Okay. So even if Islam had corrupted
scriptures in it, you would trust it. Is
that right? Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> You was born that way.
>> Were you uh were you born a Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> You was born alabotized.
>> I born Muslim. All I'm Muslim.
>> Born fool.
>> Mhm. Okay.
>> She said she [laughter] said
>> yarn fool going to die fool. That's what
I'm talking about.
>> I'm a die fool.
So um
>> that's so funny.
>> You you you said that uh that Islam is
the only religion that hasn't been
changed and that's why you trust it.
>> Just only that because I told the we
because it's like I'm believing in one
God. is clear like I don't have to be
confused like 320 which one is my God
Jesus and then the father and then that
and that too much too much confusion.
>> So when it comes to Allah's attributes
you're not you're that that all makes
perfect sense to you.
>> I told everything make perfect sense for
me.
>> You said Islam
>> you said everything in Islam makes
perfect sense for you.
>> Yes it is.
>> So let me ask you this. Let me get your
thoughts on something. When um when it
says that people will bow down to and
prostrate to Allah's shin, you believe
that Allah has a leg.
>> That's people saying Allah is nothing
like him like Allah. He is different.
>> Interesting. So
>> nothing is like Allah.
>> Allah's nothing. There's nothing like
Allah.
>> Nothing.
>> Do you do you have a shin?
>> Do I have one?
>> Do you have a shin? A shin bone? A leg?
>> Yes, I do.
>> The Quran says that Allah also has a
shin. Maybe you misunderstand it.
>> So help me understand it. Help me
understand Allah's shin. How how does he
have a shin if there's nothing?
>> No, he don't have nothing. He don't have
nothing.
>> Me
>> Allah told you nothing is like Allah. He
don't have shin. He don't have nothing.
All this like he don't come as human as
a man as this. No, no, no, not all.
>> But the Quran says he has a shin. So can
you help me understand that?
>> Okay, show me.
>> Oh, you want to see the verse where he
says that?
>> The verse on the screen. Yeah, I have to
read it. Okay,
>> with the Quran now that's what I'm
talking about.
>> And I didn't know that you have to go to
you have to have about it.
>> So you want to talk about
>> reading that Quran if you know how it's
work.
>> Okay.
>> Not like how whatever you do like
however you want to say that says that
and then goes like that. No.
>> Right.
>> You have to learn it a lot.
>> You got to learn it. You got to learn it
a lot.
>> That makes sense.
>> Yes. What is love to know it?
What's What's that? Thank you. 68. Oh, I
was in 69. 6842.
All right. 6842.
Okay. I'm going to show you what it
says. All right.
>> You can see my screen, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Not that great. Can you get it closer?
>> Yes. Sorry. Hold on. There we go. You
see it? It says, so this is chapter
68:42. says, "Remember the day when the
shin shall be laid bare and they shall
be called to prostrate, but they the
hypocrites shall not be able to do so."
So it says Allah has a shin that that
>> it's not saying that. Can you do with
the Quran with the Quran with Arabic,
please? And get it closer.
>> Oh, you
>> not like whatever he said is going to be
like this because you think it says the
like you and me as a human. No. Get it
closer, please.
>> Get it closer. Use that.
>> Yeah. I can't see it.
>> You can't? Oh, how about now?
>> Yeah. And then make it in Arabic.
>> Oh, you want Arabic?
>> I don't know where you got it. That's
>> okay. Let me put that. You read Arabic?
>> Yes, of course.
>> All right. There's the Arabic.
>> Okay. Get
your glass.
>> Does it say the shin there?
>> No, I I swear I can't see it. Let me get
my glass or something. I I can't.
>> Okay.
>> Why is the the screen is so far? Like,
>> what do you mean? It's It's as close as
I can get it. Like put it on your
screen. The whole screen.
>> You can't see it.
>> How How close do you need it to be? Like
that's close. It's really close. I'm
looking at it right now.
>> It's on.
>> Okay. I see some words. Yeah. Okay.
Let's
>> Oh, now you see some words.
>> Okay.
I Yeah, I really got the first verse.
Hold on.
>> Does it say shin?
>> Does not say any shin.
>> It doesn't say.
>> No.
>> Oh, what? What does it say? And I don't
really what is in English, but that's
not a sin that I'm talking about. But
>> you don't you don't know what it say in
English, but you know it ain't saying
shin.
>> What does sake mean?
>> Sakin. Okay, let's go to the Arabic. I
mean the Hold on one second.
>> You see how it says the shin?
>> No.
>> The shin like if it say even the shin in
English, it's not that mean the shin
like you and me. It's not it's not
doesn't have any shin or any leg
anything. We look like nobody see Allah.
Nobody see God. Like
>> not a human like Jesus. Come on.
>> I'm confused.
>> That's what he thinking.
>> I I I understand what you're saying.
>> You can't just take that say you think
it's Sheen and then you kind of make is
a human like you have a chin, he have a
leg, he has No, it doesn't work like
this.
>> No, no, no.
>> Well, this is this is the confusing.
This is the confusing. Just one one
second, my sister. This is what is
confusing for me
>> is that you said that the trinity is so
confusing and you don't know who your
god is.
>> I'm sorry. I don't want to second.
You're interrupting me. I just let you
talk. Please don't interrupt me. You
said that you don't know about you know
the the trinity is so confusing to you
and you know it's just um you don't know
who your god would be in the trinity.
You know is it Jesus? You know having
human features but you know in Islam
it's so simple and you get it. It makes
perfect sense to you. Yet we have here
that Allah has a shin and you can't tell
me what that is. Matter of fact, it's
not that you can't tell me what it is.
You're saying it don't. That ain't it.
You're sitting here telling me that the
Quran saying what it says ain't saying
what it's saying. So I I'm I'm all out
confused. I don't know what to believe
with this Quran. You You can unmute
yourself now. But you telling me that,
okay, if Allah has a shin, he has a shin
that's just not like our shin. How does
that make sense? instead of listen
I'm telling you if we don't know how
Allah look like and oh can I talk
>> help me Allah look like Allah is not a
human Allah is not like you or me but
humans different and then not a she that
you have it or me I have it say if you
understand that that's why to explain to
you Allah have a not a she my shin and
your sh does Allah have a shin Okay. So
just listen to me.
>> I'm telling you, we don't know. Nothing
is like Allah. If you have that Torah,
>> okay, got
>> nothing. Nothing. We don't know how it's
look like.
>> I got you. I got you.
>> We don't know. All we know is powerful
king.
>> I got you. Relax.
>> So with with the same thing I hear
everything you're saying. Yes. Allah has
a shin, but his shin is not like
anything we can imagine. There's nothing
like Allah. goes beyond what we can
explain, what we can talk about. There's
nothing like him. Fine. In the same way,
there's nothing like God. There's
nothing like Yahweh. God is a trinity
because there's nothing like him.
There's nothing in this world that you
can compare to Yahweh, the true God.
There's nothing you can point to that is
triune like he is. Therefore, it seems
like my God, the Trinity concept, really
fits what [clears throat] you believe.
That God is inexplainable. That's what
it sounds like to me.
>> Listen, listen. It's makes sense to you.
Makes sense to you. The God, your God,
which is I don't know how which one is
the God, your Jesus, the father, the
spirit. I don't know. We don't know.
>> He doesn't He doesn't have to explain.
Use it. Wait. User. Let me finish. Okay.
user. He doesn't he doesn't have to.
>> You're not going to talk. Okay.
>> But you didn't understand it. You didn't
understand it. He doesn't have to
explain it. Just like you don't have to
explain what it means for your god to
have a shin. You don't understand your
god having a shin, but yet you say your
god is perfect and it's one god and he's
just almighty being and you don't have
to explain these type of things. Well,
then we can do the same thing to you.
The trinity is unexplainable. We believe
in one god. That's why you guys fall
flat when you try to debate the trinity
because your god doesn't ask one
question about your god. You can't
answer it. At least we can at least go
into some sort of depth about our god.
Like goodness.
>> Yep. Yep. Go ahead and watch your hijab,
man. Where Hey, where are those songs
at, man? That word sent us.
>> They should be in your email.
>> Okay. If do you think you could upload
them here?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Let me see.
>> Okay. In the meantime,
>> are they in my email?
>> Yeah, he sent it to you. Kai Templar,
you're on stage.
>> Yeah. Hi.
>> Hello. Are you a Muslim?
>> No, I'm an ex-Muslim actually, but I've
been listening to your part for a while.
I'm just amazed I'm I'm just amazed of
the level of patience you got, brother.
[laughter]
>> Thanks, man. Thanks. We're we're we're
bringing up Muslims to debate, but I I
appreciate that, man.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm calling from Tunisia. Do
you know where that is? I think I'm the
only non-Muslim in this country.
>> Praise God. That means you could you
could start a revolution.
>> Yeah. I'd be lynched before I get that
far, but uh thanks for the idea anyway.
>> God bless you, man.
>> Yeah, you too, brother. Go ahead.
Thanks.
>> Hello. Are you a Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. Life, can you multitask?
>> Yeah.
>> You can talk to this guy and and get the
songs.
>> The songs are already in.
>> Are they Oh, so they're uploaded on the
Streamyard.
[music]
>> All right. Yeah, we on now. That shirt,
stop running. Watch your hijab. You just
left us. Okay, we Oh yeah, we on now.
All right, you you can talk to this
brothersu.
Yushamitsu is that am I saying your name
right? Yamitsu.
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome. Uh do you have a nickname? Do
people call you Yushi?
>> No. Yushimitsu is is appropriate.
>> Oh, all right. Okay, cool. Well, you
Yushim you said Yushim is appropriate. I
can call you Yushim.
>> So he said no. Oh, so I got to say your
whole name.
>> Yeah, like Yushimitsu like that. Yitsu.
>> Call him you.
>> Like,
>> can we call you you?
>> You have to say it like the Japanese
way. Yushiitsu.
>> Okay. Do you have an abbreviation? Like,
you have an abbreviation I can use.
>> Uh, no.
>> All right. I'm going just I'm going just
say bro. All right. Is that cool? I'm
just call you bro.
>> Tell them no. Say no. No. Don't let him.
>> Say no. You got to You got to use my
name. Tell them.
>> Yeah. You got to use my name.
>> That's crazy work, man. All right. So,
look, man. Would you uh would you
believe in a religion with corrupted
scripture?
>> No.
>> Okay. Uh why not?
>> Doesn't make sense logically to believe
in a scripture that's uh been corrupted
by man. It makes sense to believe in in
you know communication that can be
relied on that comes straight from God.
>> Right. Exactly. So how many sets of
scriptures was revealed in your
religion? You have the Torah, you have
the Injil, you have the Psalms and you
have the Quran. Right. No, it's more
than that, but like yeah, those are
those are the few mentioned in in the
Quran.
>> Okay. And out of all the scriptures that
were revealed in your religion, how many
of them were not corrupted?
>> Um, I believe the Quran is not
corrupted. Yes.
>> Okay. So, everything else in your
religion is corrupted except for the
Quran.
>> Yeah, the previous scriptures sent to
the previous prophets were corrupted.
Yes.
>> All right. So [clears throat] you just
said you wouldn't believe in a religion
with corrupted scripture, but you just
admitted that you believe in a religion
full of corrupted scripture because the
majority of the scriptures revealed in
your religion, you just admitted all of
them are corrupted except for one set.
So you do follow a religion with
corrupted scripture, right?
>> No, I don't think it follows. Your your
argument is I don't think it's sound.
>> Well, okay, explain why. Because the
religion of Islam is really restricted
to what the what the Quran says and
teaches. We only confirm what agrees
with the Quran um that were part of the
previous scriptures. So it has no it
doesn't follow it's a nonsecular to say
that the entire religion is false just
because we claim that the previous
scriptures were false or or corrupted.
>> You sure about that?
>> Yes sir.
>> Okay. So first I do want to establish
you do agree that majority of scriptures
revealed in your religion is corrupted.
Before we go into what your Quran says
you do agree that majority of the
scriptures revealed in your religion is
corrupted.
>> So here how are you using the term
religion? Are you using the word that
was revealed to prophet Adam through
prophet Muhammad peace be upon them?
>> How many religions does Allah have?
>> Well define religion in this. So the
message is the same in terms of
religion. So the the main message define
religion for me in your question please.
>> What
>> your God's belief system that you have
to follow be implemented for you.
>> Yeah. So at different times in the past
you're making this more difficult for
you.
>> How many religions does Allah have?
>> He's making it more difficult.
>> Yes. He's making it more more difficult.
>> You're the one that don't know what
religion mean all of a sudden.
>> Did Abraham follow different religions
than
>> brother? How many how many religions
does Allah have? one or two or three or
four.
>> Well, the religion in this context where
we have a final message that's you know
that you know in terms of laws and
beliefs if you're defining it that way
then we have only one religion that is
acceptable by God.
>> Thank you.
>> But in terms of
>> so and how far does that how far does
that religion go back?
>> Um so this religion starts with the
revelation of the Quran.
>> So Muhammad has a different religion
than the previous prophets.
>> Exactly. No, no, no. You're not you
don't you're intentionally
intentionally.
>> Hey, logic phase one.
>> You guys can be
>> as long as he as long as he stays here,
he won't get cooked.
>> It's clear that you guys are just being
acting up to in this in this subject
matter. You know exactly.
>> Pay attention. You just said your
religion starts with Muhammad. That
means that none of the other prophets
were Muslims.
>> Yeah. in this different religion.
>> What do you mean this definition of
religion? Dude, do you believe that all
of the other prophets were Muslims or
not? Was Moses a Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So then your religion doesn't
start with Muhammad.
>> Well, the message the core message of
the religion of monotheism and
submitting to God is the same. Are you
are you not tracking?
>> I'm not asking you. Let me ask a
question. Let me ask a question.
>> [laughter]
>> Yes.
>> Abraham of the same religion as most you
you should you should me too. I I have a
question on what you said. You said that
the Quran is the final message of your
religion.
>> Yeah. Can you answer my question real
quick in a in a second cuz that's a
that's a that has nothing to do what
we're asking right now cuz that's not
for us to answer.
>> So you you said that the Quran is the
final message of your religion.
>> Yes. So what other message was before
the Quran in your religion for the Quran
to be the final one meaning the last
one? What was the first one?
>> Uh the first one would have been the
message given to prophet Adam.
>> All right. So how how many religions is
that? That one or two? I
>> I don't know. I mean there were there
were 124. So there were 124,000
prophets. Prophets of who?
>> So if you're defining prophets of God.
So if the Quran is the final message out
of these 124,000 prophets, it's the
final message. That means it's coming in
a line of message messages that precede
it of the same God, meaning the same
religion, right?
>> Yeah. The core message of monotheism is
the same but with uh slightly different
laws perhaps,
>> right? You would have different Sharia,
you know, different Sharia for different
generations or whatever. However, the
same theology, the same religion is held
by all the prophets, right?
>> Uh, in essence, yeah, the the core
message is the same.
>> Okay. So, I I don't know cuz it sounds
like it's a yes or no. Is
>> playing games.
>> I'm playing games.
>> Yeah. We're going to we're going to give
you one more one more chance, big dog.
Do the 124,000 prophets, Muhammad
included, do they all have the same
religion or do they have different
religions? Yes or no?
>> Bro, how many times do I have to explain
this? Like, are you guys really really I
mean,
>> I've seen your debate.
>> My bad.
>> I've seen your debates. Go
>> explain it one more time.
>> No one's begging you to convert to
Islam, just so you know. I mean,
>> hey, and trust me, you don't got you
couldn't pay me. You couldn't pay me to
join this non relligion religion.
>> My gosh, bro.
>> You You couldn't offer me a thousand
Horries
>> that all look like my wife and I convert
to your religion.
>> Couldn't do it. It's funny. Somebody put
in our Kora video because all when when
we were asking her was Muhammad correct
or was he wrong in his oath? It it it
depends logic and somebody put in the
comment section fail safe. Say it
depends so you don't get cooked. Or they
said say as long as you say it depends
then you're good because you don't have
to commit to a position. You can always
be vague and and all over the place and
as long as you just it depends. The
religion of yes no and the religion of
it depends.
>> That's it.
>> What
>> are you a Muslim?
>> Yes. Alhamdulillah. Are you Christian?
>> Yes. Hallelujah.
>> Hallelujah. Do you know what the
hallelujah means?
>> Yes. It means praise. It means praise
Yahweh.
>> Yahweh. Huh? You believe in three gods?
>> Do you believe in 99 gods?
>> You believe in three gods. You believe
that Jesus is
>> You believe You believe in 99 gods. You
believe Allah is a shin, huh?
>> Your god Is your god a curse?
>> Is your god a shin? You prostrate to a
shin. Is your god a shin?
>> Is your god a curse?
>> Is your god a shin?
>> Your god died on the cross, huh?
>> Your god showed his leg bone.
>> Your god died, huh?
>> Your god showed his leg bone. Huh? Is he
shaped?
>> You have three gods.
You're 99 gods. One god 2 3 4 all the
way to 99. Huh? Is he
>> You have 99 problems.
>> Did he shave?
>> Oh my gosh.
>> Did he shave before?
>> Do Do people prostrate because Allah
shaved his shin?
>> Listen listen. Allah is my God and your
God and your forefather's God. Okay. And
he's Jesus God. The one God that Jesus
prayed to. I prayed to him.
>> Do you?
>> Congratulations, man.
>> Would you follow a religion that's uh
that has corrupted scripture? corrupted
scripture. You should not talk about
your Bible. Don't talk about corruption.
You are the last person in this world to
serious talk about corruption.
>> Would you follow a religion with
corrupted scripture? Yes or no, my
friend.
>> Do you believe in three gods? Yes or no?
>> Goodness, man.
>> Hey man, you a you a full Muslim. Get
off the stage. Where does where where it
at? You a full Muslim. Where's it at? I
don't see the full Muslim one, man.
>> 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 Where? Yeah, of course he
sent the full Muslim one. Word. Okay,
word real quick. Send that full Muslim
song, bro, to life's email. It should be
It should be full Muslim. Well, at least
we'll just uh we'll give him this.
>> Go ahead, watch your clip back. [music]
Let it sink in. Come back when you get
down. Go ahead, watch your clip.
>> WATCH YOUR CLIP BACK.
>> DO YOUR HOMEWORK FIRST UNTIL THEN. YOU
messed [music] up. Don't request up. You
messed up. Don't request up.
>> Don't request up. Hey, you messed UP.
DON'T REQUEST UP. HEY,
>> DON'T REQUEST UP. GO STUDY.
>> WATCH YOUR CLIP.
>> Go study and watch your clip back,
Krypto man. Go see if Go see if you did
well in this conversation, man.
>> Door, I think I I think I talked to him
before. I'll do her.
>> Good evening. Good morning.
>> Good evening. Thank you. Come again.
>> Yes.
>> How you doing?
>> I'm doing well. I'm doing well. Can't
complain at all.
>> That's what I'm talking about. Life, can
you come on camera? Sorry, my talking to
my co
Why did you
>> Can you come on? Hold on. Can you come
on camera? Life co-host.
>> Uh, no. No.
>> Why did you say that?
>> No. Not Not you. Next time. Abdor.
Abdor. I'm talking to my co-host. Not
you. Not you.
>> Okay.
>> Life, can you please come on, bro? Can
you come on? Thank you. Don't do that
again. You all right?
>> I'm trying to be, man.
>> Okay. So, yeah. Welcome to the stage,
updo. It's good to have you.
>> I'm trying my best around here, man.
>> Life, can you would you like to engage
with him?
>> Uh, sure. Sure. Chill. Just don't say
nothing. I'm doing how's it going?
>> I won't say anything.
>> I'm good. Good. Yep. Let me uh give me
All right. Uh would you believe in a
religion with corrupted scripture?
>> Why would you say that?
>> Well, because it's a solid question.
Muslims don't like corrupted scripture,
right?
>> You could say that.
>> Okay. So, would you believe in a
religion with corrupted scripture?
>> I'll say I believe in God if that makes
everything simple, easy.
>> Okay. Thank you for that. But I want to
know, would you believe in a religion
with corrupted scripture?
>> No. When you say corrupted, what you
mean? Can you explain?
>> What? Okay. Um, corrupted meaning the
scriptures have been changed and altered
away from their original revelation.
>> Now we don't know what corrupted
scripture is.
>> Is it like due to translation, due to
the method of preservation?
>> Altered scripture.
>> Do you want me to move on?
>> We don't maybe altered scripture. I'm
sure you get that.
>> You just say the word, man. I mean, you
you got mods. You can Are you modding
here?
>> No, I wouldn't say either. The question
itself is still blunt. You know what I
mean? It's like it's just ambiguous.
It's like what are you trying to do? Are
you trying to
>> The question is The question is
ambiguous.
>> Yeah. Where are we going with this?
Yeah. We
>> Let me ask you Let me ask Okay, let me
ask you this. You tell me what is
corrupted scripture? You tell me. I want
to learn from you.
>> I don't you making it sound like I best
my life on, you know.
>> Don't worry about it. Don't worry about
it, bro.
>> Thanks for coming, man. Thanks for
coming.
Enjoy the Enjoy the Mid.